[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we're gonna tackle the
question do youtubers watch YouTube and
the only youtubers that we can really
answer for are to ourselves but us two
youtubers yes so it's really do we watch
YouTube videos but do you've to Burres
watch youtube videos sounds better so
that's the question that we're exploring
we're going to explore our interesting
relationship with YouTube viewers given
that we are also creators and I think
let's just get right into it right up
top a little bit of a confession oh it's
a confession it is a confession cuz I it
doesn't make me feel a little dirty I
think I mean not dirty but I just feel a
little guilty I mean the way that I'm
going to answer this question we've been
on YouTube since basically the beginning
not technically the very very very
beginning but you know month less than
one year in yep we were in it on it
doing everything we could not knowing
how or even what this could be to get to
this point and then still struggling
with whatever else is next in
association with our professional
exploitation of YouTube as a platform
oh yeah right art because I do do you
remember the period of time before you
know the story of why we ended up
uploading stuff to YouTube was people
were taking our videos that we had on
rhettandlink.com/store paying for the
traffic but then as they watched them
but then we realized that they could
just download the videos have them
locally on their computer and then
upload them to YouTube where people
started watching them do you remember
watching youtube videos both
or we discovered that someone had taken
our videos and uploaded them to YouTube
I don't know I don't even recall if I
knew that it was a thing a thing because
we were focused on our own website using
QuickTime like you said but then Apple
video podcasts which still exists but
came out about the same time and we were
focused on that and what we could create
that was like we just thought that was
we knew what Apple was so isn't IO this
is this is legit when you try to get
something on here but there was a
barrier to it but to continue my thought
we now I mean oh our entire livelihoods
to YouTube as a platform we would not be
where we are I would say we would not be
who we are if it wasn't for YouTube and
of course be like I'd be wearing tank
top of course a lot of other things too
I'd be wearing a lot of tank tops but if
goatee if you remove YouTube from this
but from the influential things which
have baked us to be the way we are we
would be totally different
of course we professionally we would be
totally different so we owe so much to
YouTube as a platform for the
opportunity it gave us and still gives
us and so I do think it is interesting
given the way that YouTube has been so
instrumental for us to explore how we
actually experience YouTube as a user
but not as a creator but as a user but
the funny thing is is that at least what
we want to talk about first is how it's
almost exclusively our experience with
YouTube even as a user was in the
context of being a creator it wasn't for
entertainment purposes it was so let's
just come out and say it business
purpose let's just just come out and say
it rip the band-aid off at the time
confess it right now yeah we don't watch
YouTube mmm I need to put my tank top on
and shave my goatee in and go home
yeah that's my shank shamed Rhett is
whereas the tank-top man has a goatee I
don't know why he slumps a lot - yeah
he's 6:1 slithers around we don't watch
youtube videos well ok let's say that
often that is instance that is a
sensational claim
let me justify it or X I don't know
where the word I'm looking for it I say
let's just leave it lay unless let's
trace our relationship with YouTube like
you were doing and let's just come back
to it because I don't think it's that
simple
you know it's not well we don't watch
YouTube we just upload videos to YouTube
we we have an evolving relationship with
YouTube as a viewer and I think it
raises some big questions about where we
if we want the platform to go somewhere
and for the audience's to grow in a
certain way don't how come and and if
we're a part of that as creators
shouldn't we also be a part of that as
viewers we probably should be so so
let's come back to that I will take take
a second to let you know that Jacob just
pointed out that this podcast will be
live on the day ten years to the day
from our the anniversary of us starting
our YouTube channel is that what you
said well what the current starting
starting to eat the GMM channel starting
rhettandlink - okay the YouTube channels
because because that's been like 12
years but the retin link to the good
mythical morning channel mm-hmm which
was Rhett link to at the beginning well
happy Anniversary we're gonna we've been
10 years with a second channel which
evolved into the good mythical morning
show yes
huh the good mythical morning I feel
even more guilty for saying I don't
watch YouTube okay so I remember those
early days and I remember what I was
doing when I when I went on a YouTube
mostly for me it was going to the home
page and seeing what was up there most
often from barats and bereta oh yeah you
know Joe Bereta you may know him now of
the valley folk
formerly of SourceFed
before that he was with barats and
bereta famous comedy duo that we that we
idolize and despised all at the same
time but they along with everybody else
I was on the front page or the home page
was was somebody decided to put him
there right and so we would watch I
remember watching their videos in
thinking like man they really got this
figured out it was like a stress watch
it wasn't watching it for entertainment
purposes he was simply watching it to
see what could happened I remember
looking at them and seeing they were
number one at one point 65 thousand
subscribers and I was like how how in
the world how in the world can that
happen how can you connect with 65
thousand people yeah so we would be what
in horse you focus in on her than an
arena you focus in on beretta beretta
because they were most like what we saw
that we could be there were certainly
all types of stuff on the homepage
mm-hmm everything you can imagine
and I'm not gonna mention cats just a
mad but of course cats but we honed in
on that because well I wouldn't say they
were our competition we we would
consider them that but they wouldn't
have at the time because these guys in
North Carolina I didn't know about us
but I would I'd watch or watch you watch
one of their videos or something else
that was like you watched me watch I
would watch you watch sometimes secretly
what know I would just glance over at
you watching something and good it's a
funny video it's supposed to make you
laugh or at least smile and it and I
guarantee you or we didn't you look at
our faces it was just like and it had
nothing to do with what we thought of
barats and bereta except for what they
made us think about us it's like the
first time it was watching it was
watching you're like a rival yeah well
do you remember the first time we ever
watched and again this was a stink space
you think video we'd have like a stink
face flight of the conchords not a
YouTube you not youtubers but I remember
we were at a hotel room
traveling I don't remember where we were
and why we were there but they had HBO I
ain't got no HBO at my house i'ma turn
HBO we turn to HBO on and there's these
two New Zealanders up there on stage and
it we were doing some musical comedy at
the time and we just sat there and just
looked at them in silence with just like
a slight grimace yeah how are they so
funny
how are they ah what what is it going to
take to get to be like those guys so
let's just get like hate watching let's
give up
musical comedy we didn't give up we we
didn't give up but we felt like it but
that's how we interacted with YouTube
was okay this is what we're trying to do
now I mean we started uploading to our
Channel
the rhett and Link channel and we were
waiting we're just looking for an
opportunity to get something that could
be featured on the home page I mean that
was the Holy Grail but everything else
we watched sketch channels mostly it
wasn't a lot of music I mean
musical comedy on YouTube well we also
watched videos see other we tried to
watch and find the videos that other
people were watching so that then we
could create a video response to those
videos so that then people would watch
our channel so I it was also it was also
strategically driven and so professional
again it's like those skateboarding
twins
I don't yeah well I didn't even watch
the video Rhett just tells me there's
piece of skateboarding twins wins
they've got likes it we need to make a
response I was like okay I know I never
watched the video yeah you didn't about
watching the video there was a video of
a man drawing a perfect circle on a
chalkboard
and everybody loved it now you can see
that a million times on YouTube but
there was the original dude who could
draw the perfect circle I saw that on
Reddit last week he's still being me
still impressive I mean if I could stop
right now and just watch somebody do
that I would do it but we did it and we
made a response video just so people
would come and watch our videos and of
course then we would watch our response
video to see other people watching it so
it was it was it fun he
wasn't entertainment it was desperate it
was it was a job you know it was like
we're trying to make this work and so
whatever is working everything that is
working needs to inform what we're gonna
do on our own terms in hopes that that
will also work right and I mean even as
we got successful it didn't change you
know we we've always been older than the
that what I felt like was the average
YouTube viewer I think this is something
that will keep coming up well and they
average YouTube creator really yeah I
mean we got into game late man I mean I
I had a chin strap didn't ever go - you
didn't have a mustache yet but I was
like 28 right I mean with children yeah
it's like who who who else has kids on
you - who does it at that point too late
but we did I mean that shaycarl guy he
had a he was a DJ I knew he had kids but
he was just doing videos because he was
a DJ he wasn't doing videos with his kid
right and I remember seeing those videos
well in Charles Trippy before that right
cuz it he started it before Shay right
right around the same time but I saw
that they were those were the guys who
were doing oh now they're doing a daily
video and that was much late that was
that was a couple of years later but
yeah I'm swore you long time yeah but
watching watching them again while I
like I find those daily vlogs that they
did back then I would find them I would
understand why they were entertaining
but I didn't even open myself up to
being entertained by them there was not
a part of me that was like I'm going to
enjoy this and make a consumer-level
choice to enjoy this but it's it was
still in research mode and I guess maybe
there were some things that happened
that made me crack a smile but I still
was thinking hmm these guys are doing
this it's every single day and then that
was without began to plant the seed even
for gmm back in a day for us but we
missed the whole community aspect I mean
when we had
DeFranco on-ear biscuits I remember he
told us the story about how he got
started and it was very much he was just
a a member of the YouTube community he
was commenting and conversing with other
people and then he started making
whatever he made at the time and how it
it morphed into what it is now but you
can still see how I mean his content is
driven by and in many ways the community
that was something that weed has never
got we just we didn't look at it
properly we missed that we didn't
understand I'll blame it on our age but
it's like you know we would I get we
just go home and watch television or
movies mm-hmm we would come to work we
sit at our desks and we'd watch YouTube
videos to inform our business well but
we didn't really talk to people I mean I
mean video responses perfect example
that's a great way early on to foster
community oh I watch your video I've got
something to say in response to it no
I'm just gonna do who are these two
jerks silhouetted by light trying to
make a joke about these two
skateboarding twins that's what we were
doing were a couple of jerks you know it
was it was so self-motivated 100% so we
really missed the boat earlier we were
at home watching unity I was watching
reams of DVDs of alias that's what
that's what I was actually enjoying I
mean I don't even know where we got him
but Jesse came home with just the Box
seasons of alias yeah Jennifer Garner
man Sydney Bristow I mean it was
electric it was a great show I want to
see she's got that new movie where she's
she's bloody and she's going after
people really Jennifer Garner's back and
she doesn't care what's in your wallet
anymore man she's coming for your wallet
oh it's like a total role reversal it's
the old it's the old city Bristow man
she's gonna be disappointed in my wallet
I got a thin wallet man I mean I've got
a license I've got a health card I've
got let's are going away I got a credit
card debit card but I have no cash while
that's gonna be on a chip man it's gonna
be an inside your hand you don't need a
wallet what's in your chip is what
she'll be saying Oh she'll be back on
that but what's in the what's in your
forehead the mark of the beast Sydney
Bristow but I remember in the first
Youtube official gathering YouTube live
2008 in San Francisco we were barely
invited they had a main stage inside
Katy Perry is gonna perform in a
sequined bathing suit I remember that
you know her because she kissed a girl
and that's all right at the time right
mm-hmm
but then they had a trailer like a like
a flatbed trailer out out front that
they made a stage out of that I wasn't
even sure if it was part of the venue
and when that's where they put us we
were allowed to get on that and sing
like five songs yeah I ain't I don't
know I don't even know how we were
invited they gave out flip phones they
gave out flip phones and we didn't even
out flip video cameras those look mber
those little flip video cameras that
were before you had cameras in your
phone they gave those out but we didn't
even make that list they didn't give us
those oh no I mean I think they gave
shaycarl 100 yeah all those people were
up front and we were like barely in and
then that night in the lobby of the
hotel you've got ryan higa philip
defranco bo burnham boburnham is in and
Anthony from Smosh um a bunch of other
people there was a photo that was I
think Joe Bereta poster because Joe was
there and we were on the fringe of that
photo we're like we we weren't allowed
into the board game that they were
having because we didn't know anybody
they did you know they might have known
of us but they knew each other because
but they knew each other like it was a
sense of community that we didn't
understand they had been like one
additional you together well but they
were talking a
lot of them we're talking to each other
online yeah I I wouldn't peg bo burnham
as one of those people but he was also
very funny and very cool so there he was
in the middle of oh yeah I don't know
yeah maybe he was talking to him I don't
think he used he was a video response
type of guy but anyway we just didn't
well I think we missed the boat on that
right but then in spite of it we were
still able to get some traction but it
so that didn't draw us in either that
was the the big thing at first was the
community and the connection and the
conversation it wasn't just the quality
of entertainment that the funniest skits
you can ever find or hear forget SNL I
wasn't really but how does this relate
to you your your use of YouTube where
you going with this I'm saying that it
just as time progressed and we started
to get successful we still didn't really
invest personally we didn't talk to
other creators right but what about and
then we do watch the use of the of the
platform for your own personal
entertainment that didn't start
happening and no it didn't I mean in it
and what we just said the confession is
that hasn't changed a lot so let's take
a let's take a break and come back and
talk about how we use it today and if
anything has changed in terms of the way
we view the platform and maybe what we
what we desire for ourselves and what
you might be able to help us change is
gonna come but first we want to let you
know that you can grab the shirt that
I'm wearing or one very much like it I
just grabbed it as well as the the mugs
that we are drinking out of and the jars
that we are drinking out of we are both
double-fisting not because we're super
thirsty but we're super thirsty for you
to buy these jars and mugs like yeah we
got limited quantity limited quantity
decreasing every day go to mythical dot
make a crease more mythical dot store
you're thirsty or you need clothes
yeah well it's really not like that
basic of a need kind of clothes it's
more like it's clothes you want to wear
I don't know I shouldn't brought that up
mythical dot store you want to know how
I use YouTube now as a viewer here's one
example here's a story warning it may
involve a little nakedness Matt I don't
know how I'm gonna tell this story how
far should I go I should have told this
story in my own brain before I'm telling
it with my mouth this is very rich guys
there's some pitfalls to this story I
don't really I just don't want to over
share okay probably too late okay um
let's see last week I didn't I didn't
have to be here at a certain time I
actually knew you weren't gonna be here
until later which I'm like I can't beat
so I was hanging out at home oh yeah
my Kristi was also at home and nobody
else was but there and so we just had
some in what we just had some what
happened well we had some business we
had to take care of Mike you know when
the kit when the kids are around I mean
it's just like it's like a um it's like
a zoo at my house I got sounds like it's
got three kids
okay the zoo I've seen him act I'm not
talking about that at all I'm just
saying that you see you've already gone
off track in the house brought up zoo
and then helped in the hustle and bustle
of life at home there's certain things
that you put off like a stack of mail
that you need to go through okay so
let's just say that Christina had a
stack of mail that we needed to go
through
you probably shouldn't use that analogy
with her just so you know baby you know
I don't know what you're talking about
enjoying I'm literally talking about May
and we're enjoying each other I think of
it like a stack of Mayor you know what
but you could say but technically I am a
stack amazing but I don't know what
you're referring to because I'm just
talking about a literal male here okay
him ail so um we're like you know the
best place to sort through your stack of
mail is in the bedroom is in is in our
bedroom upstairs right and then but I'm
like but she's like well there's the
painters coming over to paint our
bathroom yeah which is in our master
bedroom even who's the painter in the
analogy Oh a literal painter it's all
literal okay
so I'm like instruction at your house
got it and the painter has a key to our
front door so and then lots of times he
comes in when we're not there because
the lockbox and he'll just come up to
our bedroom and start painting oh well
so lock in the front door the house
doesn't help us
but locking the deadbolt on our door
does help us which we did room door and
so took the mail up there Christie lock
the deadbolt and because you want to
have a secure zone when you're sorting
the mail right yeah because there's
confidential documents right sensitive
information so sort of the mail that was
great it's good sense of accomplishment
every time you do that right yeah
something you got to do
painter didn't show up just like we're
we're in the clear everybody wins
and then Christie goes over to the door
and she's like shaking the door and I'm
like what are you what are you doing
she's like the deadbolt is stuck we're
locked in our bedroom and I'm like well
let me handle that I mosey on over there
of course I was naked because
yeah you don't want the mail did soil
[Applause]
yes you don't want to get a stain I'm
like you're right this the deadbolt is
stuck like I can see it move a little
bit but it didn't go it didn't retract
far enough for the door to up again the
deadbolt is literal right yes man I'm
trying to I want to parse because if
that's metaphorical scheme does
metaphorical with that we have a medical
situation if the deadbolt gets stuck oh
gosh I needed a good laugh today man
this is exactly what I needed
of course this is all gonna get cut this
is just for me and you okay so I'm like
let me step in and shimmy the deadbolt
there's no hope with that I mean it's
not the type of thing you can put a
credit card in there I didn't have one
of those anyway I actually looked around
it's like in my bedroom I didn't have
anything sorted mail a small wallet and
it's a double door so at the top there's
one of those things that like if the
door were open you can pull it you can
pull down on the thing that goes into
the ceiling cut to the to lock the
swinging door like not swing your door
but non-private door push really far and
try to shimmy that but I thought my
fingers are gonna get caught and then
I'm like okay I have to we're gonna have
to unscrew the the deadbolt and
disassemble it and or you know your
eyebrows are raised just because I said
unscrew the deadbolt we're gonna have to
disassemble the deadbolt but I need to
get a Phillips head screwdriver don't
have one of those up here so I'm like
well you just throw me a lot of
softballs but I'm just let them all go
by I'm going waiting for the home run so
then I'm like I'm going to have to go
out on our balcony jump off our balcony
into our pool oh just lamb dish in order
to get up into the pool in order to get
down to go into my garage and get a
screwdriver to then throw back up to you
Christy so you can disassemble the
deadbolt while I'm down there
naked well I'll put on swim trunks which
I did and so we had this whole plan and
then I'm like you know what don't panic
don't do that you can injure yourself
jumping into your pool from the
second-story that's crazy
you have your phone go on YouTube so I
went on a when I want well actually just
googled I'll see how this for how to
unstick a deadbolt mm-hmm that'll do
this on YouTube it and it another day
YouTube goats YouTube video came up and
I started watching it and it was a guy
telling you how to step by step but it's
magic
right there I knew watching it video so
much better than just reading it just
out of curiosity how what is the process
well as I started getting into it all of
a sudden I hear this noise and Kristi's
over there with a dr. pimple popper
blackhead remover which was given to us
by dr. pimple popper it looks like a
however long that is
I'd say that's three and a half nine
inches oh gosh
three and a half inches long it's just a
metal tool and she was over there just
going at the door with it and so all of
a sudden she's I'm like I'm like about
to get to the part of the video where
it's helpful he's about to pop the lock
and then all of a sudden she's like I
did it she gets it she got it she got it
she saw the problem didn't need you so
didn't need me didn't need my swim
trunks didn't need my screwdriver and
didn't need youtube hmm but I watched
YouTube that's the point of my story
last time I watched YouTube let me tell
you I was sorting mail actually there's
one more part of the story
so we I'm like I'm like celebrating I'm
like sorry I didn't believe in you baby
you did it the door swings open the
painter standing on the other side and
he had been there as a whole didn't even
show up that day
what a jerk yeah painters are really
really unreliable your dad's a painter
very reliable painter interestingly I
recently used it was a big story
just say that's how I use YouTube well
and I and I use YouTube and this in a
similar way I mean I wasn't sorting the
mail but I was having car problems and
that is not a euphemism and it was you
know we're using the FJ Cruiser the the
4x4 truck that we have been off-roading
in before but we have not done it lately
so it's been sitting under a cover for a
pretty extended period of time kind of
sad but we're actually using it in a
we're using it for YouTube we're using
it in a good mythical morning video
coming up but I needed to drive it in as
they were going to conduct some tests
for the purposes of how we're going to
use it and I've been letting it sit so
long that the battery was dead and then
I popped the hood of my car to use my
car to try to charge the battery of the
truck and the car is a 2017 model always
to fancy-man
you had to go on YouTube just to skip to
the chase here just to figure out figure
out how to get where the battery where
the terminals are you couldn't find the
battery uh-uh the batteries in the trunk
guys what the battery for my car is in
the trunk did YouTube tell you that
check it did you know that we have the
same car the battery is in the trunk did
YouTube tell you that uh I don't know
I'm not what YouTube told me I open up
the trunk open up the hood and I'm like
it's a battery and then I'm like this
whole thing just looks like a computer
it looks different than the last time I
opened a hood of a car you know I'm
saying like things have changed it's
clean and there's I couldn't even find
the dipstick and oh and listen that is a
euphemism but but so then I'm like where
is where are the battery terminal 3/4 of
the way down your stack of mail Oh
a make and model of the car that I have
and it turns out that the batteries in
the trunk but they because they know
that you might want to connect it's
under the spare tire don't go which
incidentally I watched another YouTube
video about how to find the freak how to
get the freakin lug nuts off of my type
anyway
so it turns out that they they send
terminal connections up to the front of
the car and there's like a positive and
a negative but you have to know where
you're looking so you can still do
traditional things like clasp your
jumper cables on there and slowly charge
to think but again did YouTube tell you
that yeah like a okay because when you
type in battery terminal locations on
this particular model of car the first
thing that came up was a YouTube video
and it was a it was a like a four second
video of just a guy going he has a phone
he's just like there and there and
that's it it's a pity he'll slap for as
long as like thank you it's the best one
just said like 10 seconds of intro and
then three minutes of all right click
the Bell and the like and subscribe cuz
I do laughs there was exactly what I
needed it was right there that's
beautiful
but you can't monetize you clip that
small so I'm again I go back to business
for these things and like I'm I'm like
we're like old guys who are just so
practical it's like well YouTube's gonna
tell me how to do things how to build
something how to fix something
I think but do you entertain yourself do
you okay we use it I'm watchin alia well
I watch YouTube less now than I did five
years ago I mean since the success of
good mythical morning well I've actually
we have a system for how we churn out
these episodes and it's not so dependent
from video to video on learning from
what else is happening on YouTube to a
fault I think it's a I mean the I think
it's actually a problem that we can get
too lackadaisical in like the rhythm of
how we produce good mythical morning
that we used to because every video was
started from scratch on the rhett and
Link channel or like okay what do we
put on the menu at the end or what are
we gonna use these annotations for how
can we get more people to actually watch
it you know every video was like a
strategy session to learn from the last
thing and that doesn't happen every
single day now and we've got a whole
team of people that put out the show so
I'm not as motivated to scour YouTube
every day to figure out what someone's
doing better than us and that that's a
problem but it it I it actually gets me
further away from now I'm not even bunch
of videos at all unless I need to shimmy
a dead bolt you know um well I I feel
like I am watching I am watching so you
feel like you're but I don't feel like
it is it is definitely not my primary
source of entertainment and I let me
just tell you how I find myself using it
right okay so what's your routine again
the well the way that we're logged into
YouTube is we are logged into YouTube on
the the account that manages the good
mythical morning channel right I think
we can select some other accounts that
are kind of tied into that but
essentially I don't have a personal I'm
not a personal user on YouTube I'm just
kind of watching it through these
managed accounts and so who the good
mythical morning channel is subscribed
to which is a conglomeration of people
that we subscribe to back in the day
along with typically people who are
guests on the show will get subscribed
to and this there's like you know I'm
saying I'm not in control right we're
not we're not yeah I'm not actively
managing it so I don't have actually
have a channel where I am putting in my
preferences or Google is recording my
personal preferences so I don't have a
personalized curated experience as a
user now it would be easy for me to do
that because I could just simply to make
the decision to always watch YouTube
through like my personal Google account
but I don't so just right off the bat
because I want to check in and I want to
see things that I can see in the creator
studio back in for our channels right
and I don't want to be constantly
switching so right off the bat I don't
have a user experience so the algorithms
and the
the robots behind the scenes that are
supposed to be determining what I need
to see are not having a two-way
conversation with me so I don't look at
the subscription tab what I do is I'm
just like trending and I go to trending
for two reasons three reasons reason
number one is to see if we're there
right I'm gonna go and see if there's a
mozilla GMM that has made it to the
trending page number two and and and I
would say that there me there are many
legitimate arguments that it doesn't
matter but what's on trending you know
there are people who will make that
argument that it seems to matter less
than it did at one point but it's give
you that even though that may be true it
still is some sort of quick check
indicator of something that would make
us feel good about ourselves and also
make us feel like we need to apologize
because we're in there a lot the second
thing I would just want to apologize
that that good mythical morning is in
trending so much wait we haven't done
anything illegal I'm not gonna apologize
I'm very happy about it second reason is
to see what else is trending again from
a business standpoint to be like who
else is trending well who's breaking
through who in the old school the old
guard is still Oh Phil DeFranco he's got
he's got something else trending he
stayed he has stayed the course as well
that's cool and I and I will actually if
I see Phil trending and he is talking
about something that I'm interested in
some news item or whatever I'll click on
it and typically go to him talking about
that specific thing
oh I don't watch the entire thing I go
to him talking about that specific thing
so I will go I will go a layer deeper
and this order the third reason is is
there something that I could be
legitimately entertained by right now
but when you do when you do that level 2
and level 3
you're you still only have a limited
window of time that you're willing to
give to YouTube well and I will say
gonna be like what four minutes this
does not happen in what I would call my
designated entertainment window right my
designated visual entertainment window
now this may be not just because I'm old
but because I'm married but and because
of my schedule and the fact that I've
got kids and we are typically you know
hanging out or whatever and then they go
to bed and then Jesse and I make a
decision to visually entertain ourselves
unless we want to sort the mail which is
also very fun and productive right and
then you at the end you don't have to
there's a sense of accomplishment that
the times you can sort the mail and then
watch something and sometimes you can
watch something in sort the mail I
typically recommend sorting the mail and
then watching something because if you
watch something and get too tired you
don't want to sort the mail I've I've
tried to sort mail while watching
something it depends on what you're
watching but I just think that it's
disrespectful to the to the mail to the
creator of the program you're watching
no I don't think they know to the mail I
think it's disrespectful to the process
and I'm only talking about literal mail
again then when I make a decision to to
visually entertain myself it is that's a
weird slogan for vision to visually
entertain yourself go to youtube.com
slash Brenton link to it it is most
often television series on platforms
such as Netflix HBO Amazon Amazon
Showtime Lulu it is you know it's it's
series that nine times out of ten
friends who I respect have told me about
right and then I get into some of the
things that i love like Handmaid's Tale
which is you know the second season is
over at this point I absolutely love
that show and every single time an
episode came out Jesse and I would
rearrange our visual entertainment
schedules so that that would be the next
thing that we enjoyed together mm-hmm
and so you know typical sort
like 40 year-old viewing habits now
movies less and less and less why
they're too long right yeah they're
they're too long but yet they're not
long enough I absolutely love films and
it's a passion of ours
and we hope to make one another one
besides the one we made a long time ago
but when I just think about my lifestyle
I think about the fact that okay kids
are in bed we've got time if we want to
sort the mail we definitely can only
watch a television show like lists 40 to
60 minutes is all we're gonna give to
this 90 min 2 hours 3 hours remember 3
hour movies no when does that happen of
like that has the time and so I I
believe I don't believe that the golden
it is a tangent but I don't believe that
the golden age of television is simply
based on the fact that Netflix decided
to start making television I think it's
definitely based on a disc combination
of the amount of programming that is
available people's schedules and I think
that the length of a television series
has fallen into a sweet spot that has
become easily insertable price shouldn't
say insertable easily accommodated by
people's modern-day schedules definitely
tangent and I but that's I have the same
okay I have the same routine
I mean Kristy and I we just never sat
down and watched a YouTube video now
there's a television within eyeshot of
our kitchen and sometimes we can we can
like throw a youtube video up there well
I'll say the kids will do that sometimes
just to like watch a YouTube clip and
the kids will watch I'll I'll look over
their shoulder I mean Lincoln watches
some gamers and I just he has an
assortment of youtubers that he'll watch
you know and they've started to move
through things like Lily used to be
really into Minecraft and stampy cat and
that's a thing in the distant past now
and she's very into Netflix
and she's totally she went through Parks
and Rec and now she's on to the office
and I'm extremely proud of her and
that's what my kids do my kid
binge-watch thinkin Lincoln old shows
Lincoln doesn't Lincoln's more of a
YouTube watcher and then Lando is not
yet so but so Lincoln I'll look over his
shoulder and watch gaming videos mm-hmm
you know those let's play things I've
heard of them this lock watch youtuber
does he artist Shepherd watch YouTube
shepherd watches Shepherd will watch
shepherd watches good mythical morning
Shepherd is like the one person in my
household who watches good mythical
morning mm-hmm and like pretty
consistently and he watches I've noticed
that he's there's a couple of other I
mean I couldn't even tell you who they
are but basically he's really in a wrote
wrote it's at roblox or roblox roblox
roblox
and so he plays that game all the time
so he watches a lot of videos about that
so let's play instructional videos about
that because it's all the games with him
the program mm-hmm
but lock watches he just goes through a
bunch of shows it shows that I really
want it like he actually is almost all
the way through Breaking Bad by himself
and I wanted to watch that with him like
I was looking forward to that being like
oh you come out on Netflix yeah but now
it's on Netflix and I might see him
watching I'm like whoa you're already
watching Breaking Bad without me you're
like in season 3 he's like dad it's the
best show I've ever seen and then I'm
like okay missed that bonding
opportunity but he the YouTube that he
does watch is basketball related videos
so but not shows no he there's a few
there's a there's a button first of all
you you wouldn't be surprised but
there's like basketball instructional
videos but then there's guys who just
talked about like there's NBA
compilations but then there's also just
like basketball experts and people
taught it and so he's into all that
content and he was also he was really
into
complex and hot ones and so us being on
hot ones was like at that point that was
the coolest that we have ever been that
was the coolest that I've ever been as a
dad is when I was on hot ones The
Tonight Show five times who cares right
is what it is a 14 year olds perspective
the only videos that I've watched there
wasn't when you introduced me to
primitive technology this is the guy
where is he Australia I believe he's it
you know it's it's silent you just you
just see footage of him some time lapse
mostly just cut of him
creating huts and stuff and I would just
watch that because you could watch there
there was like one sitting where I
watched three of those in a row and he
doesn't I mean he puts so much effort
into each video because there's so much
effort into the actual physical thing
that he's documenting that you can go
and watch his you can watch this whole
channel in a few hours and by the way
there's there's like ripoff channels
that do the exact same thing now he it
is in the Far North Queensland Australia
there's there's people in other places
now who arm like making swimming pools
and they're like they don't seem to be I
there are more questions raised about
how legitimate limited talking no they
do so he's found he created a job
created his love and they are emulating
it and it's getting just as many views
because they're making but I question
whether they're doing it as legitimately
primitive but I have found myself
watching those and then every time a bad
lip reading trends I will make sure to
watch that but but it's but it's not in
the shared time well first of all if
you're in a if you're in a relationship
with somebody and you've chosen to to be
visually entertained with them like we
have there's not a lot that I watch on
my own and so I think that right off the
bat that ends up kind of changing your
habits when I'm alone when I do have an
option to watch watch stuff alone and I
don't choose to what sometimes I'll be
I'm gonna watch a war movie because she
would never watch this
but those are the times in which I find
myself being personally entertained by
YouTube and because you're watching a
war movie on you - no no no when I'm
alone okay and I decide not to go go and
I'm like oh and sometimes I do it a
little bit out of again like a sense of
guilt like man I should be watching
YouTube there's so much stuff on there
and how do you do it you've you've
literally spent an hour like to have
like a session of like I'm just gonna
watch YouTube's and see what happened hi
youtubes I watched about an hour's worth
of cringe compilations that was a loop
that I got lost in one night cringe
compilations it such as highly recommend
I'm not well this is ironic based on
some of the comments that we've gotten
before on some of the crazier things
that we've done how is it it's good
right let's grow a pair I need a penis
alright you don't get it lined up with
me chomp in three two like anytime we've
done anything that made anyone feel
uncomfortable like the vast majority of
the mythical beasts have reacted
negatively to it so I don't expect the
average GMM watcher to enjoy these
things you probably hate them but
there's just something about the dark
sinister side of me that loves cringe
compilations and so you're trying to
find one that okay this one's got 12
million views that in it it's got a long
runtime so this is the one I'm gonna
watch I found one guy that just numbered
him Grimm's compilation five no there's
six it's hard there's seven there's
eight cringe all night brother I do
remember that
Lilly sat down a couple weeks ago and
she was like mom I'm gonna I'm gonna
give you a crash course on vine which of
course is no longer this happened
recently yeah
did you tell her that it's about Blatt
form she was she knows this she's just
like she pulls up vine compilations on
you your kids watch that like anytime my
kids are
like we do like a social event at your
house I've noticed that by the end of
the night all the kids are watching fine
compilations and so Christi didn't do it
but I said memorizing I sat down with
Lily and I watched I'm almost an hour
and a half of vine compilations on
YouTube and how did it make you feel
about yourself I was like oh I get vine
I should have done this when vine
existed maybe I and then I could have
been a part of the zeitgeist but don't
you feel like you just ate a lot of
candy oh yeah it's it's like it's like
you can go to almost fun cuz lily and I
were just laughing and it said it's just
it's
I mean incessant is usually negative but
it was like a barrage of laughs and it's
so quick it it's like a weird Clockwork
Orange situation where I feel like my
eyelids of pill back and I'm just like
it is like we're doing it's like sitting
down and just eating just like a pound
of bacon you know what I'm saying it's
like it's watching the cringe
compilation I just in every once in a
while I was sitting down and eating a
pound of bacon is awesome but isn't it
but again I don't want to do it with my
wife here's here's the thing and I did
talk Christina watching Game Show
blooper those are in again that's a
compilation yeah
and it's I mean so the so the way that
we have found to enjoy YouTube as a
viewer is just these compilations that
range from like decent to absolutely
crappy well and let me let me make an
observation about this because I think
this is again this is where I feel a
little shame is that none of the stuff
that we've described is content that was
created yeah we're the YouTube audience
in mind in the way that good mythical
morning what we do you know so we've got
a show that has been seen as much as any
show when you're talking about a show on
YouTube and we create that with the
internet in mind that's what we do for a
living but yet what we enjoy on YouTube
is not anything that was created with
the YouTube audience in mind now let me
just say there are some exceptions and I
want to talk about one because I tweeted
about this shoutouts right I'm seeing on
you wanna follow the best and in the
YouTube world at least one time I talked
about it go make sure you check that out
no we know talking what no tell bit no
talking of mail sorting on what is that
saying
Shane Dawson oh yes so I talked about
first of all this tannic on thing that
happened you know around the same time
VidCon did and if you if you know us you
know that Tana Khan is not the kind of
thing that we would get roped into
typically but I was very interested in
all the hubbub around it and then I
found myself I saw that Shane had a
really the thing that got me was that he
had a very long video that was trending
a thirty minute video maybe it was
longer than that I was like this is
interesting and again my initial
interest in it was the fact that I've
always kind of known and I kind of keep
up with what Shane is doing because he's
again he's an OG he's constantly
innovating and kind of reinventing his
channel and he's got a super successful
podcast and he signed this table
somewhere he's a trend setter man and so
I've always respected how he's kind of
inventing himself reinventing himself
and also inventing trying new things on
the platform also doing it with YouTube
in mind from the get-go and so I was
like okay what's he up to and I would
add with artistic integrity yeah and so
I see just anicon thing and I start
watching it and I am immediately
mesmerized and I think that I'm just in
one of my toe dip YouTube sessions which
is like 99% of my youtube watching is
like checking in on something even if I
like something I don't watch the whole
video reach a conclusion about what he's
done and then I'll send you a text he
informed by you send you a text right
let me tell you what Shane's doing I
watched two minutes of it and know
everything about it right and I'm like
yeah I watched the thumbnail so I oh I
go literally what I do watch thumbnails
and I feel like I know enough you go so
I go into this thinking that this is
just an educational experience and I
find myself being drawn in to the
content in a way that I would be drawn
into and this is what I said on the red
MC Twitter account like making a
murderer on next documentary which was a
documentary series that was mesmerizing
and my wife and I enjoyed it together
right and so and I watched this
45-minute thing and then immediately
tweeted about it and said you know this
is I don't know what it was but it was
essentially this is got me this content
has absolutely sucked me in in the way
that what I consider a sort of a higher
tier of content traditionally has sucked
me in and of course I watched the whole
series and then he since then he's done
I did the Jeffrey star series which I
haven't watched yet but the way that he
has approached it is again it's in this
like YouTube meets this crime conspiracy
document documentary process and I'm
absolutely mesmerized it and I was like
I think I could just watch this for
entertainment purposes what and and also
the thing that was weird about it is
that it was long so it was it fit it
began to fit into that little window of
time that sweet spot the 42 to 59
minutes sweet spot that entertainment
kind of fills in my life right now which
is so smart of Shane to start pushing
the content to those links and so it
it's funny because at the same time that
Shane is doing this and he's not the
only one again we just don't get dig
deep enough to know I'm sure you guys
would be like and that's what we're
gonna get to in a second is you telling
us who we should be watching the same
time ironically that this has been going
on YouTube has been doing YouTube read
now known as YouTube's premium which
incidentally there are two seasons of a
show that we made Retton links buddy
system available on YouTube premium we
have a YouTube premium account and we
have the ability to watch you
Premium and basically this whole old
fart conversation that we've been having
this whole time recognizing that we are
entertained in a certain way and we
didn't feel like you to fit that bill
previously post to address that YouTube
it's yeah attempted to address that is
attempting to address that with YouTube
premium and I haven't found myself going
to that platform in the same way that I
go to these other platforms even though
we have a show on it
I haven't even watched all the body
system what yeah I'm I did I watched all
a buddy system when we reviewed it but I
haven't watched it I don't watch it on
YouTube
I like watched it you know for
professional reasons to make sure it was
what we wanted it to be that's the last
time I watched it - yeah she watch it
it's good yeah we watched I watched part
of Cobra Kai because I was just curious
but we watched it at work and we just
judged it and said well a lot of people
really like this even friends of ours
that I respect their tastes so I was
celebrating the fact that okay this is
this is moving the needle this is
bringing people over yeah but I
personally didn't keep watching it I had
multiple mutual friends of ours whose
entertainment opinions I respect who
really likes Cobra Kai and so I first I
haven't seen Karate Kid so maybe that's
the problem
yeah well that is the bet is a big
problem as a karate kid' watcher but not
necessarily I wouldn't consider myself a
huge Crotty kid fan
I wasn't like super into it I had
trouble getting into getting into Cobra
Kai did you like her back I lot fellas
just rolling his eyes because I haven't
seen Karate Kid it's crazy that he
hasn't seen let's just start making a
list all the movies that haven't seen
alright but then there's another handful
of things and again I don't want to get
into like it I do find it a little bit
odd that I visit YouTube the homepage of
YouTube every single day for
professional reasons and I'm also a
YouTube
premium subscriber but yet what's on
YouTube premium is not on my radar
like I don't being introduced I know
there's other stuff that's on there
there's a tab you can click on but
nothing compels you to do it I I don't
find myself being confronted with it I
haven't crossed over into a place and I
also don't know if there would be enough
stuff there currently that would cause
me to then incorporate it into the
larger conversation that I'm having with
Jesse which is what do you want to watch
tonight one of my favorite things to
watch our music documentaries I mean I
mean shout-out to link Lamont on Twitter
cuz I will tweet a really good music
documentary and podcast former otherwise
how's that isn't there a music
documentary on YouTube there's one
specifically the history of g-funk
yeah and I'm like I'm gonna watch that
but I but you haven't yet going there
going I keep forgetting to go to YouTube
premium because I don't I don't think of
it that way I'm like I'm ready to watch
a documentary I don't I don't remember
that what is the plan what is the
problem here though how can two guys who
are the target audience for especially
one guy who is the target audience for
music documentaries who makes a living
on the platform who has two seasons of a
show on the exact premium platform how
come you're not watching the music
documentary that is available on set
platform viewing habits it's all about
habits I mean I'm big on habits and
systems you know that so I like I go
into my ruts and I yeah I think we're
highlighting a big problem we want
YouTube even good mythical morning I
want to grow an audience that is broader
and even older right so if we start to
see more fans join and be vocal that are
in our age range I think that would be a
good thing not to not in instead of a
younger audience or whatever but in i
just want to expand in that way but I
think in general I want to see YouTube
be a place where those people come as
well and start to see it as a
a legitimate source alongside Netflix
and and I don't I'm not necessarily so
I we can talk about YouTube premium I'm
not that interested in figuring that out
I mean obviously YouTube is invested in
trying to figure that out and hopefully
the the people who make those decisions
and got me to a place where I was
willing to pay for Hulu and Showtime and
HBO and Netflix and Amazon and all the
things that I pay for will get other
people like me who aren't youtubers to a
place where they will pay for YouTube's
premium and it'll incorporate it but I
also feel like in the big slice of pie
that the whole pie of YouTube YouTube
premium is going to remain a very small
slice because of the billions and
billions of minutes of videos that are
being uploaded and so things like what
Shane is doing yeah I want to see I mean
just normal YouTube be something that
get to a place where you actually are
compelled to watch it for non-business
purposes right and here's what I think
but because by the way it benefits our
show so I'm just being honest that like
my professional selfish motive is that
more is that if I'm motivated to watch
other stuff on YouTube then other people
like me will be motivated to watch me
well on YouTube
well the tipping point for me is going
to be when I feel like my wife will
watch it with me if it's going to break
through into my habit it's going to have
to be something that Jesse will watch
with me and I didn't show her the Shane
documentary I think she probably would
have been interested in it because it
was fascinating and I did recommend it
to some other friends and they were like
super fascinating but I think that I
want to find that kind of content and I
think that that again this is what this
is strange it's a little bit of a
strange conversation because we as we've
said many different many times YouTube
my perspective on YouTube is that it is
largely personality based it's not
necessarily content-based right and so
and it's also the type of content that
you produce is if you're gonna put it in
front of a if you're not gonna put it
behind a paywall but it's gonna be a
vods i call it so basically it's just
free to watch it's ad-supported that's
got to be a cheap it's gonna be cheap
you know per minute you're not gonna be
putting a lot of time into that and that
tends to money and that you're not gonna
put a lot of money into that so that
lends itself to personalities that can
you know getting somebody to be
themselves it's pretty cheap and so
those are the kind of things that come
to the fore on youtube shane has found
an interesting way to do something
that's very compelling because of him
but the way he has created this craft of
these stories I mean he's investing some
money into it but it's getting a lot of
use so it's probably paying for itself
all I'm saying is that I don't think I
could get my wife excited about watching
someone vlog unless they were talking
about something very specific that she
was interested in that I probably
wouldn't be interested in right so
getting into that place where what is
the nature of the kind of content that
we want to sit down and enjoy it's
probably going to be something that has
got will watch it doesn't have to be
scripted will watch documentary will
watch reality television so I do think
that it can live just in regular YouTube
world but I don't know what it is and so
I'm asking you guys who are watching to
with your ears or with you and listening
to tell us what you think we should be
watching now it doesn't have to be
something that is like oh you and your
wife was on YouTube
that would be great what only on YouTube
but stuff yeah oh just YouTube YouTube
content now if there is a YouTube
premium show that you're like oh you got
it you definitely should watch this one
I do think you'd like it recommend that
yeah but just it's got to be on YouTube
and if you you think it's gonna be
something that we would actually be
drawn to for entertainment purposes only
and we're gonna take your suggestions
we're gonna follow those rabbit trails
we're going to enjoy seek to enjoy some
of this content and then we're going to
have a part - oh snap so this is a
grand experiment of can we find enough
stuff already on YouTube that will
compel us to then change my viewing
habits and and to shift my own brain to
see YouTube differently and I I feel
like it's so important like I've got we
got a lot riding on this am i building
this up too much am I wrong cuz I feel
like if we can't we're gonna quit then I
have a lot less hope for well where our
career is going well would you would you
watch good mythical morning if you
didn't make it oh let's table that
question I need to think about that
let's table that question for part two
and you know part twos no recommend good
mythical morning and your than your
things
and we'll watch we'll watch our own show
in conjunction with the rest of them and
then we'll let you know if we recommend
watching good mythical more yeah maybe
we think too highly of ourselves I think
that's a fair question that's a good
question
so I don't know exactly what's riding on
this in terms of what I feel about
YouTube but I'm I'm hopeful that you're
gonna help give us a shortcut to the
work that we'll be doing on our own to
find these things
maybe we'll help some of you out when we
share it on part two but there's there's
a lot to learn when we conducts it when
we independently conduct these
experiments and then report back to each
other in part two which won't be next
week yeah we're gonna take some time to
digest and enjoy your suggestions to do
some research and then when we think
we've got our answers we will come back
to you and report back so use hash tag
ear biscuits and just let us know I
think you should watch this on youtube
or YouTube premium and let me just the
last thing I'll say is it doesn't have
to I know I said some things we were
just talking you know
you know just off the cuff throughout
this thing so this is you know actually
an unscripted podcast so I said 42 to 59
minutes it doesn't have to be that
because obviously you can watch a series
of videos that would add up to that
sweet spot for me personally so just
anything you think we would enjoy for
any reason but I do think that you
should keep in mind it's things that
there's enough of it to kind of commit
to it you know what I mean it's not like
oh there's this really great video where
this guy does this one thing it's like
know a place that I could be like oh I'm
gonna go back to this place like a show
maybe a channel of personality whatever
that we can kind of go back to those are
the kinds of recommendations that were
looking for cool cool
all right guys thanks for hearing us out
I feel I feel a little dirty still I
feel like a little shame man oh wait
there's some shame except for that
except for the mail story I felt really
clean about that yeah yeah
shouldn't I mention that since that's
gonna be cut out right all right we'll
talk at you again next week and we'll be
working on your assignments hashtag ear
biscuits
[Music]